bonsoir ce serait pour ces jeunes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va parler bien sûr de péplum puisque
jonathan lambert et pascal dubois
jonathan lambert qui m'a dit je lui au
téléphone ce week-end
il m'a dit quoi qu'il arrive je vais
arrêter l'antenne de débite je ne sais
pas par quels moyens
mais à un moment je vais arrêter la
diffusion de tout
[Applaudissements]
trescal alesi alors que ça faisait beau
pitbull et alain d'un personnel je veux
dire ce qui va se passer là ça reste
entre nous un bijou pas mal ces partis
cités la balle au delà le perdant doit
enlever le reste le reste du peu que
j'ai déjà oui oui ah ben je vais mais
tout nu à la ba oui si je perds voisine
attention c'est parti à trois points
allez allez pascal bats c'est le jeu oh
là là là là haut
[Applaudissements]
ne sera pas là la tension y est partout
ouais non ça c'est celle là ça suffit
parce qu'il ya des soucis là tout est
chaud derrière non c'est faux
[Applaudissements]
c'est un garçon qui a l'air fort comme
ça mais au fond c'est un petit enfant
c'est l'une de ses premières télés il
connaît pas du tout visiter la région
je vous en faites attention vous ne
pouvez pas tout doucement ya plus de
spectateurs
[Musique]